how can we stay that and Detroit Sun
lion don't leave the sin again I besides
it's gonna be our year I think Billy
white boy Rick bit of a nickname did you
when you growing up were you known for
something that all the kids called you
something
McConaughey was always my nickname
McConaughey nicknames I love giving
nicknames but new things really having
every step of me just didn't say just
went to my last name McConaughey
y'all know who my dad is right yeah I
know what he saw I know your broke-ass
daddy what you said your name was
Brett hey white boy Rick you got some
balls coming here like you did you
should come out a skater Oh sometime
we're not like this but like you robbed
the Kmart or something what was it about
white boy Rick you know you do a lot of
you play a lot of real people a lot of
real-life stories what was about this
story that really kind of appeal to you
that family fathers and sons
I play a bad dad this role for me was my
country song
I usually don't play country songs so
you play someone who handles the
situation
this guy's it is ill-equipped to handle
it he loses he does not win he's not
good at being a dad wants to be a good
friend to his children which isn't a
recipe for being a good dad what it says
about the justice system what it says
about poverty single-parent home plus it
had this pop to goes fun it had a little
bit about a little elbow to it so it was
current it had currency and add some had
some vibe to it so where it was it was
never the script was good enough it was
never a documentary or a biography it
was an urban current flowing story that
had all really good things to say eight
pounds 14 ounces such a weight you were
born first time I looked in your eyes I
knew you were gonna be a big [ __ ] my
life was gonna be bigger than mine
look at this dad look how we're living
less hassle big I know the players and I
know the game okay come on dad I can do
this we can do this we can fix our lives
and be a family again
what do you say
you